It's the same thing in the digital world, the same thing in APIs, right? If you come across an object, a class that has a begin method, where you probably expect it to have an end method, and you probably expect those two to delimit an iterable range, right? It would be weird not to. If you come across an object that has a indexing operator, square brackets, then along with that goes the idea that, well, this should be constant time, right? An indexing operator, and it should be,
数字世界也是一样，API 也是一样，对吧？如果你遇到一个对象，一个拥有 begin 方法的类，你通常会期望它也有一个 end 方法，并且你通常会期望这两个方法能界定一个可迭代的范围，对吧？如果没有，那会很奇怪。如果你遇到一个拥有索引运算符（方括号）的对象，那么随之而来的想法是，嗯，这应该是常数时间复杂度的，对吧？索引运算符，它应该是，
random access, right? You would be surprised, you would be thrown, you would potentially be stepping into a performance pitfall if you came across an object with an indexing operator and that turned out to be quadratic or whatever. Welcome to ADSP, the podcast, episode 248 recorded on August 5th. 2025. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host, Ben, we continue our conversation on the philosophy of good software design, as well as talk about some TV shows, movies, and more. What does the future look like in a world where people are using AI? Like, my guess is that
随机访问，对吧？如果你遇到一个带有索引运算符的对象，结果发现它是平方级复杂度或其他什么，你会感到惊讶，你会感到困惑，你可能会陷入性能陷阱。欢迎收听 ADSP 播客，第 248 期，录制于 2025 年 8 月 5 日。我是 Connor，今天我和我的联合主持人 Ben 将继续探讨优秀软件设计的哲学，并聊聊一些电视节目、电影等。在一个人们使用人工智能的世界里，未来会是什么样子？我的猜测是，
similar to how the car industry has, what is it, Mizra? There's a bunch of guidelines on when you're using C++, you know, you can't use dynamically allocated. memory at all, I think, or you have to do some upfront pool allocation. Yeah. Well, here's the thing about Misra. Have you read the Misra standard? I have read bits and pieces. I've definitely not. I mean, it's pretty lengthy. So I haven't, have you back to front read it? I haven't read it back to front, but I've read parts of it. And what I noticed was that it's not a binary thing, right? It's not the case of you adhere to Misra or you don't adhere to it.
类似于汽车行业，那个叫什么来着，Mizra？在使用 C++ 时有一堆准则，你知道，我认为根本不能使用动态分配内存，或者你必须进行一些预先的池分配。是的。嗯，关于 Misra 是这样的。你读过 Misra 标准吗？我读过一些片段。我肯定没有。我的意思是，它很长。所以我没有，你从头到尾读过吗？我没有从头到尾读过，但我读过其中的一部分。我注意到的是，它不是一个二元的东西，对吧？并不是说你遵守 Misra 或者你不遵守它。
For every sort of idea of there's a rule for this, there are actually multiple rules. And they gradate the compliance, right? And so you can wave certain parts. And overall, it's a good thing, and it makes your code safer, perhaps. But there are always these sliding scales, right? So for many, many cases in there, if there's an idea of you shout, not do this then there's also an idea of now you shall not do this most of the time except
对于每一种“这里有一条规则”的想法，实际上都有多条规则。它们对合规性进行了分级，对吧？所以你可以豁免某些部分。总的来说，这是一件好事，它可能使你的代码更安全。但总是有这些滑动标尺，对吧？所以对于其中许多许多情况，如果有一个“你不应该这样做”的想法，那么也会有一个“现在你大多数时候不应该这样做，除非”的想法，
sometimes or you know that so there are so it's sort of you know there's never a hard and fast on or off binary decision or almost never um and so with all of these things it's the same way in for example like medical devices now i'm no expert but from what i've heard um and this is where the kind of regulatory stuff comes into play it is a it is very expensive to get a device a code base certified right but it's much less expensive to get an update to that device cleared right and so of course what we see is most companies most of the time trying to position their products as updates rather than brand new things to ease the regulatory burden So, you know, there are outside effects like that that come into play.
有时，或者你知道，所以有，所以它有点像，你知道，从来没有一个硬性的、非黑即白的二元决定，或者几乎从来没有。所以对于所有这些事情，情况也是一样的，例如在医疗设备方面，现在我不是专家，但据我所知，这就是监管方面发挥作用的地方。让一个设备、一个代码库获得认证是非常昂贵的，对吧？但让该设备的更新获得批准要便宜得多。所以当然，我们看到大多数公司大多数时候都在试图将他们的产品定位为更新，而不是全新的东西，以减轻监管负担。所以，你知道，有这样的外部影响在起作用。
Yeah. Yeah, I'm definitely not an expert in the area either, but I can imagine a world where there's going to be some equivalent regulation with respect to these LOMs and Gen. AI when it comes to these critical software domains. Like, yeah, I think, like I said, if you're standing up a website, no one really cares, especially if it's just for yourself, right? Yeah. Worst case, whatever, your personal.
是的。是的，我也绝对不是这个领域的专家，但我可以想象一个世界，在这些关键软件领域，对于这些大语言模型和生成式 AI，会有一些等效的监管。就像，是的，我想，就像我说的，如果你只是建立一个网站，没人真正在意，特别是如果它只是为你自己准备的，对吧？是的。最坏的情况，随便吧，你的个人工具不能用了，你得去弄清楚。
tool doesn't work and you've got to go figure that out. It was interesting working in the finance industry and the interesting part really was that was the SEC, right? Which things may have maybe different now but I'm pretty sure that the SEC is the last organ of the US government that has any kind of teeth at all.
在金融行业工作很有趣，真正有趣的部分是 SEC（美国证券交易委员会），对吧？虽然现在情况可能有所不同，但我很确定 SEC 是美国政府中唯一还拥有某种威慑力的机构。
They may have fewer than they used to. Is this just in the later administration or just? I don't know because I'm not in the industry anymore. I haven't bothered to keep up. But it is certainly true that, you know, so when it comes to corporate America versus governmental America versus regulation, corporate America always wins.
他们可能比过去拥有的威慑力少了。这只是在后来的政府任期内，还是仅仅是？我不知道，因为我不再从事这个行业了。我没有费心去跟进。但可以肯定的是，你知道，当涉及到美国企业界与美国政府与监管时，美国企业界总是赢家。
The one case where the government has or had teeth, I think, was the SEC. Who could basically come in at any time ask to see anything at all, any line of code, any transatlose. transaction from any point in history sort of thing you know they have that power well they did have and and yeah it's interesting that we and it's the same thing similar although i have much less a much less experience i did once interview someone when i was working in games and they were coming to us and they were working for they were working in in las vegas they're working on slot machines writing the code and they and they told similar stories about the nevada gaming commission you know so when it comes to money things are serious apparently things are less serious when it comes to human life sadly that is very sad i guess there is there i don't have no ideas i imagine that there's some equivalent misra for medical devices and software that lives inside those i i'm sure there has to be but this is where my i can't speak i have i have no knowledge but i i imagine they
我认为政府拥有或曾经拥有威慑力的唯一情况是 SEC。他们基本上可以随时进来，要求查看任何东西，任何一行代码，历史上任何一点的任何交易，你知道，他们有那种权力。好吧，他们确实有。而且，是的，这很有趣，我们，这和类似的事情是一样的，尽管我的经验少得多。我曾经在游戏行业工作时面试过一个人，他们来到我们这里，他们之前在拉斯维加斯工作，在写老虎机代码，他们讲述了关于内华达州博彩委员会的类似故事。你知道，所以当涉及到金钱时，事情显然很严肃。遗憾的是，当涉及到人类生命时，事情似乎就不那么严肃了。这非常令人难过。我想，我不知道，我想医疗设备和其中的软件肯定有某种等效的 Misra 标准。我肯定一定有，但这就是我无法发言的地方，我没有知识，但我想象他们
they do you know at the end of the day they're programming embedded devices they have strong safety concerns actually there was a lightning talk last CPP con from one of the people who comes to my local meetup and her name is Emily I think it's Emily apologies Emily if I'm misremembering your name she gave a really great talk she works for a medical device firm in the Denver area she gave a really great lightning talk at CPP con I will uh track that down on the interwebs and throw that in the show notes. We got down this tangent by me mentioning a couple other talks that Titus and David had given.
他们确实有，你知道，归根结底，他们是在编写嵌入式设备，他们有很强的安全顾虑。实际上，上一届 CppCon 有一个闪电演讲，来自我当地聚会的一位参与者，她的名字是 Emily，我想是 Emily，如果我记错了你的名字，Emily，我很抱歉。她做了一个非常棒的演讲，她在丹佛地区的一家医疗设备公司工作。她在 CppCon 上做了一个非常棒的闪电演讲，我会去网上找到它，并把它放在节目笔记中。我们因为我提到 Titus 和 David 做过的其他几个演讲而偏离了主题。
Yeah. Oh, yeah. Software code design. Yeah. So, I mean, and so you said you kind of start this course out on a bit of a philosophical note, you know, what is, what is beautiful code, what is ugly code? You know, how do we assess, like, what are the, what's the rubric by which we judge code to determine whether it's good or bad or beautiful or ugly?
是的。哦，是的。软件代码设计。是的。所以，我的意思是，你说你以一种哲学的方式开始了这门课程，你知道，什么是美丽的软件，什么是丑陋的软件？你知道，我们如何评估，比如，我们判断代码以确定它是好是坏，是美丽还是丑陋的准则是什么？
So I guess, you know, we don't have time for you to reteach the course right now. But maybe hit on some high notes and take us on an overview of what the journey is. I pull from design disciplines in the outside of software and sort of overlapping software, the world of the world outside, right? So I touch on things like, you know, UI design is one thing I touch on, because that's sort of adjacent to code design. And in fact, it's, you know, if you're writing an application and you're thinking about it holistically, you want to make the code harmonious with the design as presented to the user, right? So it's things like, you know, it's things that are with all these things, they seem obvious in hindsight, but they aren't necessarily obvious to think about up front. A great example of this is the desktop trash can, right? The trash can on the computer desktop.
所以我猜，你知道，我们现在没有时间让你重新教授这门课程。但也许可以谈谈一些重点，带我们概述一下这段旅程。我从软件之外的设计学科中汲取灵感，并与软件重叠，即外部世界，对吧？所以我触及了一些事情，比如，你知道，UI 设计是我触及的一件事，因为这在某种程度上与代码设计相邻。事实上，它是，你知道，如果你正在编写一个应用程序，并且你正在从整体上考虑它，你希望使代码与呈现给用户的设计相协调，对吧？所以它是这样的事情，你知道，它是所有这些事情，事后看来它们似乎很明显，但预先考虑它们并不一定很明显。这方面的一个很好的例子是桌面垃圾桶，对吧？电脑桌面上的垃圾桶。
Actually, it's only called the trash can in Apple. There's a fascinating sort of trademark copyright legal history there through the 80s, which is why to this day Windows still calls it the recycling bin. But it was introduced, at least, to the public for the first time, with the Apple Lisa in about 1983. doubtless Apple got the idea from Syrox Park I don't particularly know the history there but the question is this
实际上，它只在苹果公司被称为垃圾桶。在 80 年代的整个过程中，有一种迷人的商标版权法律历史，这就是为什么直到今天 Windows 仍然称其为回收站。但它至少是在 1983 年左右随着 Apple Lisa 首次向公众介绍的。毫无疑问，苹果是从施乐帕洛阿尔托研究中心（Xerox PARC）得到的这个想法，我不太了解那里的历史，但问题是这个，
what's the purpose of the desktop trash can right now superficially we would say well it's so you can delete things right that's the sort of obvious answer that presents itself that is not the purpose of the trash can you could already delete things before you had a trash can
桌面垃圾桶的目的是什么？现在从表面上看，我们会说，嗯，它是为了让你删除东西，对吧？那是呈现出来的显而易见的答案。那不是垃圾桶的目的。在你有垃圾桶之前，你已经可以删除东西了，
right you didn't just fill up your drive and then When you were done, oh, no, I have to get a new drive now. No, the purpose of the trash can is to facilitate undeletion. The problem it solves is that you deleted something you didn't mean to delete it, and now you need to undelete it. And once you appreciate that as the true nature, then that opens up a whole lot of other questions around the design axes.
对吧？你不会只是填满你的驱动器，然后当你完成后，哦，不，我现在必须买一个新驱动器。不，垃圾桶的目的是为了方便撤销删除。它解决的问题是你删除了你不打算删除的东西，现在你需要撤销删除它。一旦你意识到这是它的本质，那么这就会围绕设计轴线引出许多其他问题。
Right? Like, how should things be stored in there? How should things be sorted in there? right these days we're all used this is going to blow your mind but for about 30 years after 1983 it took a very long time it took till about Apple finally got all the use cases sorted out probably in about 2015 it's pretty recent history right but there are questions like should I have one trash can for the whole system or a trash can per drive you know so those that's a design choice if I have one for the system then things
对吧？比如，东西应该怎么存放在里面？东西应该怎么在里面排序？对吧，这些天我们都习惯了，这会让你大吃一惊，但在 1983 年之后的 30 年里，这花了很多时间，直到 2015 年左右苹果才最终整理好所有的用例，这在历史上是很近的，对吧？但有一些问题，比如我应该为整个系统设置一个垃圾桶，还是每个驱动器一个垃圾桶？你知道，这是一个设计选择。如果我为系统设置一个，那么东西
appear and disappear when I stick in USB sticks, right? Because the system doesn't know about it if the drive's not there, but now we have drives you can plug in and take out. So should there be one place where they're displayed or should they be per drive? Should there be one, you know, for a long time, though it was a one button interface. You could choose to empty the trash. You couldn't do anything else. And that's not good because, you know, not all things in there are equal. so yeah there are lots of design decisions that go into it and they are sort of brought more into focus by the idea of what's the actual problem this solves right it is not it is not the same as the trash can in my office right the physical trash can on your house is mostly for staging the trash
当我插入 USB 闪存盘时会出现和消失，对吧？因为如果驱动器不在那里，系统就不知道它，但现在我们有可以插入和取出的驱动器。所以应该有一个显示它们的地方，还是应该每个驱动器一个？应该有一个，你知道，很长一段时间里，它是一个单按钮界面。你可以选择清空垃圾桶。你不能做任何其他事情。这不好，因为，你知道，里面的东西并不都是一样的。所以是的，有很多设计决策进入其中，它们通过“这解决了什么实际问题”的想法而变得更加清晰，对吧？它与我办公室里的垃圾桶不一样，对吧？你家里的物理垃圾桶主要是为了暂存垃圾，
so you don't have to take it out to the driveway to your city trash can right that's seldom do you have to actually remove things from the trash in your house it's always a pain to do so. The system is not optimized for that. The purpose of the trash can in your office or in your kitchen is to stage as a staging area for the garbage, which is not the same as the trash can on your desktop. So, you know, just thinking about things like that
这样你就不必把它带到车道上的城市垃圾桶里，对吧？你很少需要真正从家里的垃圾桶里取出东西，这样做总是很麻烦。系统并没有为此进行优化。你办公室或厨房里的垃圾桶的目的是作为垃圾的暂存区，这与你桌面上的垃圾桶是不一样的。所以，你知道，只是思考这样的事情
opens up the ideas. It tells us, for example, that, you know, skeuomorphism while being a good teaching mechanism, making things in the computer look like their real-life counterparts, it only goes so far. That was called skewer-morphism. Skeu-O-Morphism. Skew-O-Morphism.
打开了思路。它告诉我们，例如，你知道，拟物化虽然是一种很好的教学机制，让电脑里的东西看起来像现实生活中的对应物，但它只能走这么远。那被称为拟物化（Skeuomorphism）。拟物化。拟物化。
Yeah, it's got a really weird spelling. It's Greek-derived. S-K-E-U-something. But it's the idea that digital interfaces and digital objects represent their real-world counterparts. This is why the save icon still looks like a floppy disk, right? Even though I would struggle to find a floppy disk. disc in my house right now. Oh yeah, we, we, we, we, we, we, we, we, we, we, someone made some
是的，它的拼写真的很奇怪。它是希腊语派生的。S-K-E-U-什么。但它的想法是数字界面和数字对象代表它们在现实世界中的对应物。这就是为什么保存图标看起来仍然像软盘，对吧？即使我现在很难在我家里找到一张软盘。哦，是的，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，我们，有人做了一些
remark about, uh, floppy, floppy, uh, making you old or something. And then we got a flurry of comments from people that had, had them lying around, uh, yeah, there are all kinds of things like that. It's like, it's like, it's like when you think of an icon for a telephone, right? You probably think of the classic handset from a rotary phone. Right. Phones haven't looked like that in 20 years. Yeah. Right? Pretty much.
关于，呃，软盘，软盘，呃，让你变老之类的评论。然后我们收到了很多人的评论，他们手头有这些东西，呃，是的，有各种各样的东西。这就像，这就像，这就像当你想到电话的图标时，对吧？你可能会想到旋转电话的经典听筒。对。电话在 20 年里看起来都不像那样了。是的。对吧？差不多。
Yeah, someone asked me if the phone I was calling on was a cell phone and I was kind of shocked. I was like, you know, so many forms, they have like home, work, sell. And I understand that some people have a work cell phone. But like, what percentage of folks, I don't know, I guess I've just always had a cell phone. I've never had a landline that was in a place that I was renting. And so I just kind of, like, aren't we, shouldn't it just be cell phone and like,
是的，有人问我通话的电话是不是手机，我有点震惊。我说，你知道，太多的表格，它们有像家庭、工作、手机。我知道有些人有工作手机。但像，百分之多少的人，我不知道，我想我一直都有手机。我从来没有在租住的地方有过固定电话。所以我只是觉得，难道不应该只是手机和像，
work number, you know, like, uh, I don't know, maybe it's, maybe it's different. Do you have a landline in your house? No. Um, but, but these things persist in our culture, right? If you were to signal to someone across a noisy room that they should call you, what hand jester would you use? Would you like, do that? Because with your little finger for the, for the listeners, with your little finger and your thumb stuck out and the rest of your fingers curled, when that is an old style hand set, right? Yeah. Phones these days look like that.
工作号码，你知道，像，呃，我不知道，也许是，也许是不同的。你家里有固定电话吗？没有。嗯，但是，但是这些东西在我们的文化中持续存在，对吧？如果你要向嘈杂房间里的某人示意他们应该给你打电话，你会用什么手势？你会像那样做吗？因为用你的小指，对于听众来说，用你的小指和拇指伸出来，其余的手指卷曲，那是老式听筒，对吧？是的。现在的电话看起来像那样。
You know, look like just a flat palm. That's very, do you spend a lot of time thinking about these kind of design questions when working on like open source libraries and stuff? Because I personally feel like I don't spend, like, I feel like I have very good taste. Well, everyone does. Everyone does feel that. Yeah, yeah. That's one of those, you know, ask everybody, are you in the top 50% of drivers?
你知道，看起来就像一个平坦的手掌。这非常，你在从事开源库等工作时会花很多时间思考这些设计问题吗？因为我个人觉得我没有花，就像，我觉得我有很好的品味。嗯，每个人都有。每个人都这么觉得。是的，是的。那是那种，你知道，问每个人，你是前 50% 的司机吗？
Everyone has a good sense of humor. Everyone can drive very well. Everyone has good taste. Yeah. I do think about these things in places like, you know, when it comes to affordances, you know, in the physical world, we're surrounded by designed items that have various affordances, meaning that, you know, how to use it is, I don't want to use the way intuitive, but the affordances on the object tell you how to manipulate it. It's the same thing in the digital world, the same thing in APIs, right? If you come across an object, a class that has a begin method, well, you probably expect it to have an end method,
每个人都有幽默感。每个人都能开得很好。每个人都有很好的品味。是的。我确实在某些地方思考这些事情，比如，当涉及到功能可见性（affordances）时，你知道，在物理世界中，我们被各种具有不同功能可见性的设计物品所包围，这意味着，你知道，如何使用它，我不想用“直观”这个词，但对象上的功能可见性告诉你如何操作它。在数字世界中也是一样，在 API 中也是一样，对吧？如果你遇到一个对象，一个拥有 begin 方法的类，嗯，你通常会期望它有一个 end 方法，
and you probably expect those two to delimit an iterable range, right? It would be weird not to. If you come across an object that has a indexing operator, square brackets, then along with that goes the idea that, well, this should be constant time, right? An indexing operator, and it should be random access, right? you would be surprised you would be thrown you would potentially be stepping into a performance pitfall if you came across an object with an indexing operator and that turned out to be quadratic or whatever so so there are plenty of affordances in code that that it's worth being aware of like that
并且你通常会期望这两个方法能界定一个可迭代的范围，对吧？如果没有，那会很奇怪。如果你遇到一个拥有索引运算符（方括号）的对象，那么随之而来的想法是，嗯，这应该是常数时间复杂度的，对吧？索引运算符，它应该是随机访问，对吧？你会感到惊讶，你会感到困惑，如果你遇到一个带有索引运算符的对象，结果发现它是平方级复杂度或其他什么，你可能会陷入性能陷阱。所以，代码中有很多值得注意的功能可见性，就像那样。
yeah yeah i feel like i think you even said that at the beginning of this portion of the recording aka episode was that it's it's about how do we communicate about this stuff and articulate it because like I said I feel like I have a very good I have very good taste when it comes to design and I you know well while you were just saying what you were saying I was thinking about the title of your talk you know which was borrowed is from the Scott Myers one of his books it's you know easy to use hard to misuse that kind of thing oh yeah and and I have have a bunch of, like, that is the essence of kind of my design philosophy, but then also a bunch of rules that are just like, that I follow, you know, the verb versus nouns, which I first heard
是的，是的，我觉得我想你甚至在录音的这一部分的开头就说了，也就是这一集，它是关于我们如何交流这些东西并将其表达出来，因为就像我说的，我觉得我有很好的，我有很好的品味，当涉及到设计时，我，你知道，嗯，当你刚才说你所说的话时，我正在思考你的演讲标题，你知道，它是从 Scott Myers 的一本书中借用的，它是，你知道，易于使用，难以误用，那种东西。哦，是的，而且我有一堆，就像，那是我的设计哲学的本质，但也有很多规则，就像，我遵循的，你知道，动词与名词，我第一次听到
on a CPP cast episode, that if it's doing something, you know, name it a verb. And if it's, uh, retrieving something, you don't need to put get this, you know, just, just name it what it is. It's a noun. And, uh, the mistake of like empty on the earlier containers. It's like, is empty a verb or is it, you know, it's is empty is what you should be naming. Right. it if it's a getting back a predicate in the form of a bullion. And so there's a, that's just one example, but there's a bunch of those that I kind of have stored up just in like a roll of decks of when I'm programming and I come across a thing, like, oh, there's a rule that applies to this situation.
是在一期 CPP Cast 节目中，如果它在做某事，你知道，给它起个动词名字。如果它是，呃，在检索某事，你不需要加上 get，你知道，就给它起它本身的名字。它是一个名词。而且，呃，像早期容器上的 empty 的错误。就像，is empty 是动词还是，你知道，is empty 是你应该命名的。对。如果它是一个以布尔值形式返回谓词的函数。所以这是一个，这只是一个例子，但我有很多这样的规则，当我编程时，我把它们存在索引卡里，当我遇到一件事时，比如，哦，有一条规则适用于这种情况。
But is there a good way to distill or to articulate? So at this stage in your career, you're a senior engineer, you know the rules. Do people ask you why about those rules? And could you explain why? because that's that's kind of what happened to me after I became a senior engineer after I started managing people after I started doing code reviews and people looked up to me as a as a technical leader people would say okay you know that's a I respect your opinion but can you explain why right and especially this happens when you change jobs because you go into a new job and you're you're a senior person but now you have a whole bunch of new people who don't know you who you're going to start telling them how they should do things in a sense and you're going to it helps if you can explain the why behind it right and I found that like you I had a bunch of rules in my head and I really had to sit down and think why is that a rule where did I learn that who did I learn
但是有没有一种好的方法来提炼或表达？所以在这个职业阶段，你是一名高级工程师，你知道这些规则。人们会问你为什么会有这些规则吗？你能解释为什么吗？因为这正是我在成为高级工程师之后，在我开始管理人员之后，在我开始进行代码审查之后发生在我身上的事情，人们尊敬我作为技术领导者，人们会说，好吧，你知道，我尊重你的意见，但你能解释为什么吗？对，特别是当你换工作时会发生这种情况，因为你进入了一份新工作，你是一个高级人员，但现在你有一大堆不认识你的新员工，你将开始告诉他们他们应该如何做事，从某种意义上说，如果你能解释背后的原因，会有所帮助，对吧？我发现像你一样，我脑子里有一堆规则，我真的必须坐下来思考，为什么那是一条规则？我在哪里学到的？我是从谁那里学到的？
that from what was the situation what did it help is that a rule that applies here those kind of questions I don't often get asked why but that's because I sit in a I tower of research um and the last time i kind of worked on a team doing code reviews was a couple years ago now back then when i was on a team of folks i would get asked why and i would say i was still in the process of learning how to articulate well my reasoning a lot of like i remember my very first job which was close to a decade now i remember one time my manager you know this is me like three years into my career and you know i'm watching a lot of your videos online before we ever met you know, I'm watching Sean's videos online.
关于那种情况，它有什么帮助？这是否适用于此处的规则？这类问题我很少被问到“为什么”，那是因为我坐在研究的象牙塔里。嗯，我上一次在团队中进行代码审查已经是几年前的事了。那时，当我在一个团队中时，我会被人问到“为什么”，我会说我还在学习如何清晰地表达我的推理。我记得我的第一份工作，到现在已经快十年了，我记得有一次我的经理，那是我职业生涯的第三年，你知道，在我们要见面之前，我一直在网上看你的很多视频，你知道，我在网上看肖恩的视频。
So I am very opinionated about what's right and what's wrong. And obviously, we have to listen to these folks. They're given toxic conferences. You know, declarative is the way to go. Well, and sometimes that's the reason. Sometimes I say you should do it this way because this is what Jason recommends. And Jason has seen lots of different code bases. I know Jason personally, he has seen lots of different things.
所以我对什么是对的，什么是错的非常有主见。显然，我们必须听取这些人的意见。他们正在进行有毒的会议。你知道，声明式编程是必经之路。嗯，有时这就是原因。有时我说你应该这样做，因为这是杰森推荐的。杰森见过很多不同的代码库。我个人认识杰森，他见过很多不同的东西。
And he has come to this conclusion. So I trust that conclusion. It's not always the most convincing, but there are much worse reasons. to give. But yeah, I remember one time in a meeting, one of the folks was advocating a different way for something. And I was just like, that's, like, obviously, like, inferior. And my manager took me aside afterwards. It was very kind of her to do that and not call me out in the meeting. And she was like, all right, Connor, first of all, I want to say, like, I agree. You're correct. But, one, you got to, like, soften up on the language. No one's going to listen to you
他得出了这个结论。所以我相信这个结论。它并不总是最令人信服的，但还有比这更糟糕的理由。但是，是的，我记得有一次在会议上，其中一个人提倡用不同的方式做某事。我当时就觉得，那显然是劣等的。事后我的经理把我拉到一边。她这样做非常友善，没有在会议上当众指出我的错误。她说，好吧，康纳，首先，我想说，我同意。你是对的。但是，第一，你得把语气放缓一点。没有人会听你的，
if you're just like outright being like, that's worse. And two, it's in your best interest to learn to articulate, not that something is or isn't inferior or superior, but why? Because I'm sure you've done a lot of self-study and you have your reasons, but other folks aren't watching as many talks and reading as many books. And so it is going to be a tool in your tool belt if you are able to say, you know, for reasons X, Y, and Z, this is why we should prefer this style versus this style. But that's something that, you know, I've been working on my whole career,
如果你只是直截了当地说“那更糟糕”。第二，学会表达某事为什么是劣等或优等，而不是仅仅说它是或不是，这符合你的最大利益。因为我相信你做了很多自学，你有你的理由，但其他人并没有看那么多讲座，也没有读那么多书。所以，如果你能说出“因为X、Y和Z的原因，我们应该偏好这种风格而不是那种风格”，这将成为你工具箱里的一个工具。但这是我整个职业生涯一直在努力的事情，
Because a lot of times, someone will ask me, you know, not recently, but, you know, when I was on teams. And I'd have to think, like, you know, why is a declarative style better? You know, sure, okay, use cons as much as you can. But it's like, I look at the code. I know it looks more beautiful. It seems more readable. But just saying like, oh, it's more readable isn't actually a convincing reason for most. And I've definitely been in situations where I've given an answer that people were not satisfied with.
因为很多时候，有人会问我，你知道，不是最近，而是当我在团队中时。我得思考，为什么声明式风格更好？你知道，当然，尽可能多地使用常量。但我看着代码，我知道它看起来更美观。它似乎更具可读性。但仅仅说“哦，它更具可读性”实际上对大多数人来说并不是一个令人信服的理由。我绝对遇到过我给出的答案人们不满意的情况。
And that doesn't necessarily mean that my reason was bad. But usually there's an opportunity where you can be more convincing. And yeah, it's if you're ever thinking in your head, well, like this person's just a lost cause, there's no hope. Like, try to avoid that. Like there's always a way to be more convincing. Like the best salespeople are the best salespeople, not because they give up on the people that, you know, don't want to be sold to.
这并不一定意味着我的理由很糟糕。但通常有机会让你变得更有说服力。是的，如果你脑子里总是想着“这个人没救了，没希望了”，试着避免这种想法。总有一种方法可以更有说服力。最好的销售人员之所以是最好的，并不是因为他们放弃了那些不想被推销的人，
It's because they can sell to anyone. You know, they are very experienced and, you know, say what you will about, Steve Jobs, but he, they used to talk about him as he had this, like, the aura effect, as you entered his orbit, and you were going to tell him, you know, blah, blah, blah, blah. And then not only would you not tell him, like, give him a piece of your mind, you go away having agreed to like a schedule that was like, and then you meet and you'd be like, what did I just do it? And so the next, yeah, so like the next level of like convincing people, as you put it, is
而是因为他们能把东西卖给任何人。你知道，他们非常有经验，而且，不管你怎么评价史蒂夫·乔布斯，但他，人们过去常说他有一种“光环效应”，当你进入他的轨道时，你本来打算告诉他，你知道，吧啦吧啦。然后你不仅没有告诉他，没有表达你的想法，你离开时反而同意了一个时间表，然后你见面时会想，我刚才做了什么？所以，正如你所说的，说服人的下一个层次是，
is allowing people to convince themselves by asking them the questions that, that, that reveal the wise, right? Rather than telling them this is, this is inferior because X, Y, Z and convince them through the power of argument, the next level in part is, okay, let's talk about this. I want to ask you, you know, not even in a way that they realize, but that leads them to the same conclusions inevitably. It's so fun, this is going to be the most random aside ever, But while you were saying that, fortunately or unfortunately, Shima and I watched the most recent season of Love Island because it had become a cultural phenomenon. And it's not the world's best show, which is I feel a bit ashamed to mention it. Or should I say, like redeeming whatever qualities, et cetera.
通过向他们提出揭示“为什么”的问题，让他们自己说服自己，对吧？而不是告诉他们“因为X、Y、Z，所以这是劣等的”，并通过论证的力量说服他们。下一个层次在某种程度上是，好的，让我们谈谈这个。我想问你，甚至不是以他们意识到的方式，而是引导他们不可避免地得出同样的结论。这太有趣了，这将是有史以来最随机的题外话，但当你这么说的时候，幸运或不幸的是，希玛和我看了最近一季的《恋爱岛》，因为它已经成为一种文化现象。它不是世界上最好的节目，我觉得提到它有点羞愧。或者我应该说，有什么可取之处等等。
But anyways, we watched it. And at some point, ooh, what was her name? Taylor was dating a girl. And anyway, I can't remember her name. Clearly I was very involved in this show. And anyways, at some point something had happened. and they were going to have a conversation about it kind of a little bit awkward
但无论如何，我们看了。在某个时候，噢，她叫什么名字？泰勒在和一个女孩约会。总之，我不记得她的名字了。显然我非常投入这个节目。总之，在某个时候发生了一些事情，他们要就此进行一次谈话，有点尴尬，
and Shima and I are watching and the girl will call her Carly even though that's not her name was Carly says well how do you think how do you think I would have felt in that situation or so like basically instead of like calling him out for it asked him to explain how she might feel in this situation and like ended up at the exact same point
希玛和我在看，那个女孩——我们叫她卡莉，尽管那不是她的名字——卡莉说，好吧，你觉得在这种情况下我会怎么想？所以，基本上，她没有因为这件事指责他，而是让他解释她在这种情况下可能会有什么感觉，结果得出了和她直接指责他完全一样的结论，
they would have ended up if she had just called him out for it and Shima and I were both like oh that was that was like some emotional kung fu right there like she didn't say anything. She was like, well, yeah, yeah, I guess, blah, blah, blah. And I was like, that was a, that was a, that was a class, a class in, like, how to convince someone or, like, whatever. And anyways, that's basically what you were saying is ask the questions that get them to realize what you want them to realize. Right. That's probably easier said than done, though.
如果她直接指责他，他们也会得出同样的结论。希玛和我都觉得，噢，那简直就是情感功夫。她什么都没说。她说，好吧，是的，我想，吧啦吧啦。我当时就觉得，那是一堂关于如何说服某人的课，或者其他什么。总之，这基本上就是你所说的，提出问题让他们意识到你想让他们意识到的事情。对。不过这说起来容易做起来难。
Ava and I, we are currently watching, so this is the thing we do. This is the thing I do. I never watch TV shows until way, way after the fact. But we are watching. Ted Lassow. Oh, fantastic show. That is a great, that is a masterclass again in sort of emotional intelligence. How far are you in? We're part way through season two. Well, I don't want to, I don't want to ruin anything. One of my favorite scenes is in a pub with, uh, with, uh, is there, is there a really great scene in a pub? I don't want to, I don't want to give anything away for you to indicate that, well, there's the scene with playing darts. Yes, okay. I didn't want to say the word darts? Because then as soon as they
艾娃和我，我们目前正在看，这是我们做的事情。这是我做的事情。我从来不在电视节目播出很久之后才看。但我们正在看《泰德·拉索》。噢，精彩的节目。那又是一堂关于情商的精品课。你看到哪里了？我们看到第二季中途了。好吧，我不想破坏任何东西。我最喜欢的场景之一是在酒吧里，有，呃，有，呃，酒吧里有一个非常棒的场景吗？我不想剧透，让你觉得，嗯，有玩飞镖的场景。是的，好吧。我不想说“飞镖”这个词？因为一旦他们
started playing darts at some point, it might indicate to you that, although, spoiler alert for people that haven't watched Ted Lasso. People listening and totally getting a Ted Lasso spoiled. You know, Rupert, guys have underestimated me my entire life. And for years, I never
开始玩飞镖，这可能会向你暗示，尽管，对于没看过《泰德·拉索》的人来说，这是剧透。听众们完全被剧透了《泰德·拉索》。你知道，鲁珀特，伙计们一生都在低估我。多年来，我从未
understood why. I used to really bother me. But then one day, I was driving my little boy at a school, and I saw this quote by Walt Whitman, who was painted on the wall there, it said, be curious, not judgmental. I like that. So I get back in my car and I'm driving to work.
理解为什么。这曾经真的很困扰我。但有一天，我开车送我的小儿子去学校，我看到了沃尔特·惠特曼的一句名言，画在墙上，上面写着：保持好奇，不要评判。我喜欢这个。所以我回到车里，开车去上班。
And all of a sudden, it hits me. All them fellas that used to belittle me, not a single one of them were curious. You know, they thought they had everything all figured out, and so they judged everything, and they judged everyone. And I realized that they're underestimated me. Who I was had nothing to do with it. Because if they were curious, they would ask questions. You know?
突然间，我明白了。所有那些曾经贬低我的人，他们中没有一个人是好奇的。你知道，他们以为自己什么都搞清楚了，所以他们评判一切，评判每一个人。我意识到他们低估我是因为他们自己。我是谁与此无关。因为如果他们好奇，他们就会问问题。你知道吗？
Questions like, have you played a lot of darts, Ted? Which I would have answered, yes, sir. Every Sunday afternoon had a sports bar with my father from age 10 to all 16 when he passed away. Barbecue sauce. but that is one of my favorite that's such a great great so many great scenes from the show there are so many good scenes i mean that that scene is great that scenes really feel good but there are so many things
像这样的问题：你玩过很多飞镖吗，泰德？我会回答，是的，先生。从10岁到16岁他去世，每个周日下午都和我父亲在运动酒吧玩。烧烤酱。但这确实是我最喜欢的，那真是太棒了，节目里有太多精彩的场景。有太多好的场景了，我是说那个场景很棒，那些场景真的很感人，但有太多东西了，
like he's just he's such a great coach even though he knows well he knows some about football but he comes it comes into it knowing not much about football. And that's, and for for folks that need to be convinced, it's a show purportedly about football, but it's not about football folks. If you don't like sports shows, this isn't a sports show. And my parents like the show and my mother, uh, well, maybe she likes sports, but I don't think she does. But she loves the show because it's not really anything to do with football. Football is the backdrop of which, uh, a drama, you know, takes place or comedy drama. Anyways, you were going to say something with Ted Lasso. You know, to echo what you said about Love Island, another example of
就像他是一个如此伟大的教练，尽管他知道，嗯，他了解一些足球，但他进入这个领域时对足球知之甚少。而且，对于那些需要被说服的人来说，这是一个表面上关于足球的节目，但它不是关于足球的，伙计们。如果你不喜欢体育节目，这不是体育节目。我的父母喜欢这个节目，我的母亲，呃，也许她喜欢体育，但我不认为她喜欢。但她喜欢这个节目，因为它真的和足球没什么关系。足球只是一个背景，戏剧，你知道，或者喜剧戏剧在其中发生。总之，你要说关于《泰德·拉索》的事情。你知道，为了呼应你关于《恋爱岛》所说的，另一个例子是
of a show that just has moments of great insight. Yeah, it's definitely, I'm pretty sure I cried multiple times during that show. And that's actually not that rare. I mean, I'll cry at a Star Wars show, you know. I'll cry at a lot of stuff, though. I love crying at movies. I love crying at shows, you know, because I just, I like a well-crafted. Movies and shows should be able to make you feel,
一个充满深刻见解时刻的节目。是的，确实，我很确定我在看那个节目时哭了好几次。这其实并不罕见。我是说，我会看《星球大战》节目时哭，你知道。不过我会为很多事情哭。我喜欢看电影时哭。我喜欢看节目时哭，你知道，因为我只是，我喜欢制作精良的作品。电影和节目应该能够让你感受到，
all the emotions, right? I lived in LA for like 10 years plus, and I worked with a bunch of people who came from the movies, and I learned a ton about movies. It's not that I'm an expert or a movie buff it particularly, but I've learned enough to know that, you know, it's a great medium. Yeah, it is, there are certain scenes that I will go back, and that the, the dart scene in Ted Lasso is one of them, but, like, I probably have, like, 50 or 100 scenes across movies and TV shows that I just think are they just hits you in the fields and there's a ton from at one point the newsroom
所有的情绪，对吧？我在洛杉矶住了10年多，我和一群来自电影界的人一起工作，我从电影中学到了很多。并不是说我是专家或电影迷，但我学到的足够多，知道这是一个伟大的媒介。是的，确实，有些场景我会回去重看，《泰德·拉索》里的飞镖场景就是其中之一，但是，我可能有50或100个电影和电视节目中的场景，我觉得它们只是触动了我的心弦，有很多来自《新闻编辑室》，
was my favorite show with I actually can't remember his name the guy from Dumb and Dumber, not Jim Carrey, but Jeff something maybe Yes and that show for its time at least and also it's it's by the guy I think that wrote was it
曾经是我最喜欢的节目，有，我其实不记得他的名字了，那个演《阿呆与阿瓜》的家伙，不是金·凯瑞，而是杰夫什么的，也许是的，那个节目在当时至少是这样，而且它也是，它是那个家伙写的，我想是，是吗？
Andrew Sorkin that wrote it? It might have been I think I think it was the same guy behind Molly's game and the social network and stuff. Anyways, it has a bunch of scenes as well where it's like these, you know, speeches and stuff like that or monologues that are kind of, whether it's someone throwing darts or something's happened while the monologues going on. And that's why I love Andor.
安德鲁·索尔金写的？可能是，我想，我想是《茉莉牌局》和《社交网络》背后的同一个人。总之，它也有很多场景，就像这些，你知道，演讲之类的，或者独白，无论是有人在扔飞镖还是独白进行时发生了什么。这就是我喜欢《安多》的原因。
Andor, Shima loved season two. She wasn't a big fan of season one, but she loved season two. It took me like two months to get her to watch it. And I think I got her to agree because I agreed to something else. And then as soon as we were two episodes in, she was like, when can we watch Andor again? And how's the AFI top 100 going? Oh, yeah, we haven't, we still have the spreadsheet. I'll see if I can pull it up quickly in the last few minutes.
《安多》，希玛喜欢第二季。她不太喜欢第一季，但她喜欢第二季。我花了两个月才让她看。我想我让她同意是因为我同意了其他事情。然后我们看了两集之后，她就说，我们什么时候能再看《安多》？AFI前100名进展如何？噢，是的，我们还没有，我们还有电子表格。我看看能不能在最后几分钟快速调出来。
We definitely have slowly been making our way through it. There it is. AFI. We have across the two different lists, because there was a 98 and a 2007. It says we have 99 left. So, but I think there's like 130 videos across the. those two lists. So I know,
我们绝对一直在慢慢地看。在那儿。AFI。我们在两个不同的列表中，因为有98年和2007年的版本。上面说我们还剩99部。所以，但我认为这两个列表加起来大约有130部视频。所以我知道，
I don't know if Charite Sapphire is on there. I know you watch Characet Sofire I recommend it. I know you didn't take to it that well, but... Yeah, we weren't the biggest fans of that one. It's very British, I could see that. Did you watch The Sting yet? I don't know if the Sting is on that list, but that's a great movie. No, I think there's a, our side list of movies that you recommended that aren't on it.
我不知道《查理·萨菲尔》是否在上面。我知道你看过《查理·萨菲尔》，我推荐它。我知道你不太喜欢它，但是……是的，我们不是那个节目的忠实粉丝。它非常英式，我能看出来。你看过《骗中骗》了吗？我不知道《骗中骗》是否在那个列表上，但那是一部伟大的电影。不，我想有一个我们推荐的电影列表，不在那个列表上。
And was the Sting the one that was the British equivalent of Casablanca, or it was the British equivalent of something? Yeah, the British equivalent of Casablanca is Brief Encounter Brief Encounter, yes, that's on our list as well And yeah, I've pulled it up And the last two that we watched We're both in March
《骗中骗》是《卡萨布兰卡》的英国版，还是它是某部电影的英国版？是的，《卡萨布兰卡》的英国版是《相见恨晚》，《相见恨晚》，是的，那也在我们的列表上。是的，我已经调出来了。我们看的最后两部都是在三月看的，
And have you, in fact, have you seen Casablanca? I have not. That should be on your list too. I also haven't seen this is probably going to Well, it upset, I don't know, maybe most of our listeners haven't seen it either. I haven't seen any of the godfathers Which, Shima loves those.
你，事实上，你看过《卡萨布兰卡》吗？我没有。那也应该在你的列表上。我也没看过，这可能会，嗯，让大多数听众感到不安，我不知道，也许他们也没看过。我没看过任何一部《教父》，希玛很喜欢那些。
And they're okay. I need to watch. But we watched a Dr. Strange Love. Oh, yeah. Which, if I recall, is like the one that's super old. 1963, I believe. Yeah, 64 is what the spreadsheet says. Yeah, Peter Sellers plays multiple parts.
它们还可以。我需要看。但我们看了《奇爱博士》。噢，是的。如果我没记错的话，那是那种超级老的电影。我相信是1963年的。是的，电子表格上说是64年。是的，彼得·塞勒斯扮演了多个角色。
Yeah, she may give it a 10. I gave it a 4. You should watch Failsafe, which is basically a similar plot. came out I mean it came out the same year within I think a couple of months incredibly
是的，希玛给了它10分。我给了它4分。你应该看《奇幻核子战》，它基本上是一个类似的情节。它出来，我是说它在同一年出来，我想在几个月内，令人难以置信，
but fail safe Sydney Lamet directs great movie not a comedy we will add it to our list sting brief encounter fail safe and a stellar cast
但《奇幻核子战》是西德尼·吕美特导演的伟大电影，不是喜剧，我们会把它加到我们的列表中，《骗中骗》、《相见恨晚》、《奇幻核子战》以及全明星阵容，
I mean Henry Fonda Walter Mathau a young Larry Hagman isn't it ooh that's rough I've never heard of any of those people okay you need to watch more old movies
我是说亨利·方达、沃尔特·马修、年轻的拉里·哈格曼，不是吗？噢，那太糟糕了，我从来没听说过这些人。好吧，你需要看更多老电影。
seriously Henry Fonda, he's in 12 Angry Men. I know we've seen that one. He's your number eight. That's him, the main guy. Okay, okay. I was going to say, honestly, I remember them all sitting around a table. I did not know which number was which guy.
说真的，亨利·方达，他演了《十二怒汉》。我知道我们看过那部。他是八号陪审员。就是他，那个主角。好吧，好吧。我本来想说，老实讲，我记得他们都坐在桌子旁。但我不知道哪个号码对应哪个人。
I can remember their personalities a little bit. There was the one guy that was sweating all the time. Right. But yeah. And then it says the most recent one we've watched was a movie from 1933 called Duck Soup. Oh, yeah. Marks Brothers, right? I think.
我还能记得他们的一些性格。有一个人一直在出汗。对。没错。然后上面说我们最近看的一部电影是1933年的《鸭羹》。哦，对。马克思兄弟，对吧？我想是。
I'll take your, it says the director was Leo McCarrie. and it was Shima gave it a one I gave it a negative one the reason we watched it was because we were I think we only had like an hour and a half
我听你的，上面说导演是里奥·麦卡雷。希玛给了它一分，我给了它负一分。我们看它的原因是因为我想我们当时只有大概一个半小时的时间。
and so we ranked the movies by length and this was the shortest at like 65 minutes or something but I'm pretty sure it was 1933 so I don't think there was any audio but it was kind of this like
所以我们按时长给电影排了序，这部是最短的，大概65分钟左右。但我很确定它是1933年的，所以我觉得里面应该没有音频，但它有点像那种……
it seemed like there might have been I can't remember but it was like who's the guy Charlie Chaplin it seemed like kind of Charlie Chaplin Okay. Or like, what's the British guy, Mr. Bean?
看起来好像有，我记不清了，但它就像是谁呢，查理·卓别林？看起来有点像查理·卓别林。好吧。或者像那个英国人，憨豆先生？
Oh, okay. Yeah. It had some kind of like crazy humor. And I think it was the first of its kind, but it was way past or over our heads. And we were just like, what is this? But yes, we're making our way through. We've been very busy over the last couple months. Yeah, I know that summer gets busy for sure.
哦，好吧。对。它有一种疯狂的幽默感。我觉得它是同类作品中的鼻祖，但它太超前了，或者说我们没看懂。我们当时就想，这是什么？但没错，我们正在慢慢看完。过去几个月我们一直很忙。是啊，我知道夏天肯定很忙。
Yeah. Anyways, before we wind out, any final wrap-ups of the, software. We've got, we love Island, Ted Lassow, other stuff. We've gone on a couple of tangents. Well, I, so I have a, I have a teaser for you. I am, you may remember back in 2020, I think I told you about this talk. I submitted a talk to C++ now that was called, what is the name of this talk? Yes, I do recall this. You know about that one. That talk has evolved, and I am giving a talk, the evolution of that talk at the Denver meetup this Thursday. So, so too late for our listeners, but just to let you know, since you asked.
是啊。总之，在结束之前，对软件还有什么最后的总结吗？我们有《爱之岛》、《泰德·拉索》还有其他东西。我们跑题了好几次。嗯，我有一个预告要告诉你。你可能还记得2020年，我想我跟你提过这个演讲。我向C++ Now提交了一个演讲，叫什么名字来着？是的，我记得那个。你知道那个。那个演讲已经演变了，我这周四要在丹佛聚会上做那个演讲的进化版。所以，对我们的听众来说太晚了，但既然你问了，就告诉你一声。
I see. Is this a hybrid still, or is it just in person? It's hybrid, yeah. Okay. The name of the talk, the, so I don't want to dive into the use mention distinction here. But the talk is now called Plato, McGreet, Sartre, Carroll, software design with the masters. Should I, should I be familiar with all those names? Plato?
我明白了。这还是混合形式的吗，还是纯线下？是混合的。好的。演讲的名字，那个……我不想在这里深入探讨使用与提及的区别。但演讲现在叫《柏拉图、马格利特、萨特、卡罗尔：与大师们的软件设计》。我应该熟悉所有这些名字吗？柏拉图？
I mean, Plato, definitely. Magritte, René Magritte, Belgian artist from the mid-20th century, surrealist. That's over my head. Sassine Apaisnepepep, you may have heard. That's him. Sartre, existentialist philosopher, again from the mid-20th century, Jean-Paul Sartre, author of Being in Nothingness. Lewis Carroll, you've heard of Lewis Carroll.
我是说，柏拉图肯定熟悉。马格利特，勒内·马格利特，20世纪中叶的比利时艺术家，超现实主义者。那超出了我的认知范围。萨特，存在主义哲学家，也是20世纪中叶的，让-保罗·萨特，《存在与虚无》的作者。路易斯·卡罗尔，你听说过路易斯·卡罗尔吧。
I've heard of Lewis Carroll. I've got one of his books on my shelf, so... The annotated Alice, I'm betting. Thanks to you. I still have not read. I mean, every Christmas I tell myself, this is going to be the Christmas. I don't know why I have to read it at Christmas. I just feel like I'll have more time during Christmas.
我听说过路易斯·卡罗尔。我的书架上有一本他的书，所以……我敢打赌是《爱丽丝注释版》。多亏了你。我还没读过。我是说，每个圣诞节我都告诉自己，今年圣诞节一定要读。我不知道为什么我非要在圣诞节读它。我只是觉得圣诞节期间我有更多时间。
And then it never ends up happening. But it will at some point. All right. Okay. This has been a blast. Yeah. Good to catch up. Be sure to check these show notes, either in your podcast app or at ADSP thepodcast.com
结果从来没读过。但总有一天会读的。好了。好吧。这次聊得很开心。是啊。很高兴能叙叙旧。一定要查看这些节目笔记，可以在你的播客应用中查看，或者访问ADSP thepodcast.com。
For links to anything we mentioned in today's episode, as well as a link to a get-up discussion where you can leave thoughts, comments, and questions. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. I am the anti-brace. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
获取我们今天节目中提到的任何内容的链接，以及一个GitHub讨论链接，你可以在那里留下想法、评论和问题。感谢收听。希望你喜欢，祝你有愉快的一天。我是反大括号派。这一集还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。